من وسط المحيط الهادئ جزر سليمان تتحول
الى ملعب للتنافس الدولي في شقه السياسيه
والعسكري بين الصين والولايات المتحده
التي ترى فيها مركزا استراتيجيا مهما يمكن
ان تستغله بكين لصالحها فمع الزياده
التوتر في المحيط الهادي بشان جزيره
تايوان يعود للواجهه ملف جزر سليمان في
مشهد يعكس انقسام البلاد بين الصين والدول
الغربيه والسبب هو الاتفاقيه الامنيه
الموقعه بين الطرفين والتي حولت البلاد
لبؤره صراع دوليه واقليميه بين كل من
واشنطن وبكين التي تفعل لتعزيز وجودها
العسكري خارج ارضها حيث اكد مراقبون ان
المخاوف الغربيه تصاعدت منذ ان ان حازت
جزر سليمان دبلوماسيا الى تايوان من
تايوان الى الصين في عام 2019 وقامت
بتسريب مسوده اتفاقيه امنيه تمنح للبكين
قدم في جزر من المحيط الهادئ الواقعه على
مقربه من استراليا والتي صاحبها في
التاسعه عشر من شهر ابريل الماضي اتفاق
اني اقلق القوى الغربيه لانه يمهد الطريق
نحو وجود عسكري صيني جنوب المحيط الهادئ
وايضا عسكر جزر بحر الصين الجنوبي ومراقبه
وتتبع للقوات الامريكيه وعلى الرغم من
سريات بنود الاتفاقيه وتاكيد الصين عدم
وجود مساءا لانشاء قاعده عسكريه الا ان
واشنطن توعدت بالرد بشكل حاسم في حاله
حدوث ذلك في اشاره الى ان الصين قد تحتاج
الى جزر سليمان في انشاء قاعده عسكريه
لاستخدامها في اجتياح تايوان من عده جبهات
ويظهر الخلاف بين الغرب والصين في داخل
جزر سليمان
جزيره ماليتا مناقشات حول خطط معه واشنطن
لتطوير الميناء في اعماق البحر بينما
تابع المصالح الصينيه خطط التنميه في
جزيره
غوادالكانال الرئيسيه حيث تقع العاصمه في
مشهد يعكس طبعا انقسام البلاد بين الصين
والدول الغربيه وطبعا كل هذا التنافس نظرا
لاهميه جزر سليمان الجيو سياسييا
[موسيقى]